hey youtubers is Charlie so a lot of you
guys have asked me who is the fastest
version of the flash so I'm going to
rank all of the comic book speedsters
and the TV show speedsters there's a lot
of people we haven't seen on the TV show
yet so here we go there's also a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be
sure to click that Bell to enable alerts
so that you don't miss anything during
the break so I'm going to start with the
comic book speedsters and then I'm gonna
do the ones on the TV show just because
there are so many even in what's
considered the classic flash family so
they're about 19 people on this list but
there are a couple caveats there people
like zoom who have really weird powers
who are kind of cheating so you have
people that are fast because they run in
a straight line faster than anyone else
and then you have people's powers that
theoretically make them faster than
other people regardless of the way they
use them so I tried to account for that
with this list so starting with the
slowest working our way to the fastest
guy West Ginger Wally West's son he also
had a daughter but she's way higher on
the list so gize powers just enabled him
to take advantage of the Speed Force
make really big muscles get really
strong for brief periods of time but
they didn't really enable him to run
that fast so that's why he is
technically the slowest then you have
Liberty Bell who's a Golden Age
character that didn't actually use the
Speed Force she actually rang a special
Bell that gave her powers for a really
brief period but she could still run
much faster than a normal person enough
to make her a superhero so next on the
list max mercury he's actually from the
1830s but gained powers from a shaman
and briefly learned to use the Speed
Force to intuitively travel through time
so he was fast but he's pretty low on
the list he never really learned to use
the Speed Force or tap into it directly
the way some of the more contemporary
speedsters did next on the list is
Johnny quick one of the people to
develop the Speed Force formula the one
you hear them say out loud like Jessie
quick so he was one of the first people
to do that and enabled him to access the
Speed Force but again it didn't enable
him to tap into it as much as the other
speedsters so we should actually make
the distinction that there are a couple
different ideas when it comes to
speedsters getting their powers from the
speedforce
there's something that they called the
speed field which almost all the
speedsters draw their speed from and
then there is the actual speed force so
tapping into the Speed Force in
benefiting from the Speed Force are two
different things
so all speedsters benefit from the Speed
Force with the exception of people like
zoom I'll explain that in a second there
are very few speedsters that do not get
their powers from the Speed Force so
moving down the list just a little bit
faster trajectory who was a lexcorp's
speedster created during the 52 comic
but he was able to turn powers on turn
them off it was almost a velocity-9 type
situation but I know they used her in a
slightly different way on the TV show
I'll explain that when I rank the TV
show speedsters so trajectory in the
comics still got her powers artificially
pretty fast but still pretty low on the
list so the next is Jesse quick the
daughter of Johnny quick who also used
the same formula to get her power she
would speak the formula and take
advantage of the Speed Force
so here's where it starts to get a
little confusing because we get into
multiple Wally West's so the next on the
list is the current Kid Flash the
african-american Wally West so I know he
debuted during the new 52 but because
they retcon that recently he is now much
younger he's like a high school-aged
speedster just learning about his powers
so he will be fast one day but right now
he's towards the middle of the list next
on the list is the rival Golden Age
edward clariss from the comics he was
the very first reverse flash of jay
garrick's era he became the first
velocity-9 speedster that was eventually
lost into the Speed Force then later
came back out as pure energy and
possessed the body of max mercury for a
time so there are a couple velocity 9
speedsters on this list and it does make
them almost as fast as the traditional
contemporary speedsters but not quite as
fast so next on the list is Jay Garrick
his ultimate rifle just a little bit
faster but Jay Garrick in terms of
classic speedsters is towards the bottom
of the list like he never got quite as
fast as say like Barry or a classic
ginger Wally West so next up is inertia
who was a Bart Allen clone from the 30th
century he was created as a weapon to be
used in the past against the flash
family but also became a velocity-9
speedster so he was faster than Jay
Garrick but not as fast as Bart Allen
who he was cloned from so next on the
list is obviously Bart Allen then next
on the list is savat our just because he
had the ability to steal speed from
other people and then eventually was
trapped in the Speed Force so this is
where you start to get some twists and
turns with the way people's powers work
so you know technically if two
speedsters are running against each
other and one of them can steal the
speed of the other the slower speedster
would still be faster just because he's
slowing the other person down so because
Savitt are had the ability to manipulate
the Speed Force like that that's why
he's higher than Bart Allen on this list
and this is comic books avatar so next
up is Barry Allen in the comics Barry
Allen is the source of the Speed Force
it did not exist before his accident
when he runs he generates Speed Force so
know Barry Allen equals no Speed Force
which explains why you Bart Thawne is
not allowed to kill him
which is actually part of the plot of
legends of tomorrow this season Saul
explained that when I talk about the TV
speedsters but next on the list is
eobard thawne just a little bit faster
than Barry Allen and he also wields the
negative Speed Force meaning that he can
also slow the other speedsters down
which is why he's a little bit higher
than Barry Allen on the list but then
just a little bit faster than them is
the black flash which is basically like
the aspect of death for speedsters so
the reason why I put it on the list just
ahead of Barry Allen is because it was
created during the Wally West era in
during that time Wally was faster than
Barry
so if Wally was just barely able to
outrun the black flash that means the
black flash should be just a little bit
faster than Barry Allen and you Bart
Thawne for that matter but then next on
the list is the classic ginger Wally
West from Mark Waid era he ultimately
became the fastest version of the flash
but that was when Barry Allen was still
dead in the comics so had barry been
around they might have been just a
little bit faster but part of it is
really that they just wanted to
the flash comics - new territory they
wanted to define the Speed Force the
Speed Force is a concept wasn't created
in the comics until the Wally West era
so that's why Wally became faster than
Barry but really they're almost the
exact same speed but just Wally just
like a little bit faster next up is
Godspeed from the flash rebirth he was
so fast that he could be in two places
at once and was only defeated when Kid
Flash Wally West in Barry Allen siphoned
off enough of his speed to slow him down
so next up getting a little bit weird
there are speedsters that are faster
than comic book Wally West but it gets a
little funny so next on the list is iris
West
Wally's daughter also named iris West I
know people think iris West and they're
thinking about Candice Patton Wally West
and Linda Park had a daughter and a son
Jai West and iris West they just call
her iris West
- in the comics so she also got speed
force powers in an accident but then
became the living embodiment of the
Speed Force
so effectively for a little while she
had limitless speed force powers but
next on the list is zoom who did not use
the Speed Force he actually just
affected time relative to himself so he
could either slow you down he could
speed you up so he's the fastest but
only because he's cheating technically
you would either call him the slowest
because he slows everyone down so he
moves really slow but relative to him
everyone else moves much much slower or
you could call him the fastest so he's a
bit of a wild card pick but the very
fastest number one on the list is the
god of death Barry Allen from Dark Side
war where he becomes merged with the
black racer and gains the powers of a
new God so he is the most powerful
fastest version of any flash ever but
now moving on to the TV show so we've
seen a lot of flash family get their
powers as well as reverse flash family
like the evil speedsters so the thing
you have to remember and the thing I
tried to account for is that this is
relatively early and say like Barry
Allen's development so he's not as fast
as he will eventually become so this
list is current as of right now episode
9 in season 3 of the flash but first is
Jesse quake she got
her powers last year during the big
particle accelerator accident when they
tried to reboot Barry's powers as well
as Wally West who is next on the list
got his powers recently because of the
Philosopher's Stone but really what that
was doing a lot of people are confused
about this flash point Wally got his
powers in an accident while he was
racing his car so that was like the
lightning that struck Barry in season
one of the flash so the current version
of Wally that got his powers from the
Philosopher's Stone that was really just
restoring the original version of
speedster Wally West
so technically Wally's powers don't flow
from the Philosopher's Stone they still
come from the Speed Force and I know
they made a big deal about him being
faster than Barry but that's just at
this point in his development so next is
the TV show version of the rival edward
clariss
little bit faster than wally west not
quite as fast as say Barry Allen or some
of the other new speedsters likes avatar
so next on the list is Jay Garrick not
quite as fast to say Barry but
understands the Speed Force and can use
it better than Barry can so that's why
he's able to chase Barry through
wormholes yank him out of the time
stream when he's trying to reboot
flashpoint again that actually happened
in episode 2 where he tried to go back
another time Jay Garrick just joins him
right out so Jay Garrick is a much
better fighter but his top speed is
still slower than Barry Allen's so next
on the list
obviously Barry Allen who is suffering
from comic book Wally West's mental
block right now so even though Barry is
faster than most of the other flash
family he'll get much faster once he
overcomes that mental block he'll have
to in order to defeats avatar so a lot
of people are wondering about this how
fast will he get so think about how fast
avatar is right now he will be faster
than that but not until the very end of
the series it's all about progression he
evolves just a little bit more each new
season Grant Gustin teased that we would
see a new suit soon he said the Barry's
due for a new suit that's probably going
to be a flash forward where we see the
older version of Barry Allen who will be
much faster than current Barry Allen so
get hype about that
but next on the list is eobard thawne TV
show reverse-flash is a little bit
faster than barry then next on the list
we get to our velocity 9 speedsters so
we learned that velocity 9 made
trajectory almost as fast as zoom but it
was completely unstable so her body just
flew apart at the seams
same thing with zoom that was also
faster than Barry Allen because of
velocity 9 and the fact that he was
stealing speed from Barry but was
ultimately carried off by the time rates
so number 1 fastest speedster on the TV
show right now is sabot AR because he is
stuck in the Speed Force so instead of
running through three-dimensional space
like all the other speedsters he
actually jumps into the Speed Force this
extra dimensional place runs through
that and then pops back out so
effectively it enables him to be in
almost all places at once because he's
pure energy
so until Barry also learns to do that he
will not be as fast as avatar so that's
going to be one of the new tricks that
he has to learn by the end of the season
so here's my big question for you how
fast do you think the Barry is going to
get at the end of this season in what do
you think that his new suit is going to
look like and do you think that it'll be
a flash forward situation or do you
think that they're going to bust out the
flash ring remember they teased that
last season in season 2 he had the flash
ring in earth - Harrison wells was like
give it to me maybe I can figure it out
so they just put that on the shelf they
haven't come back to it since then
meaning that I think that we'll see some
flash ring later this season but just
for the nitpickers out there for those
of you asking is God speed or TV shows
avatar faster technically Savitt R would
be faster because God speed is all about
splitting himself into two and every
time he does that he splits his power in
half so each of the two would be slower
Salvatore would kill one of them and
then he would automatically be slower
permanently but congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner alex Persaud you
win a flash ring just be sure to private
message me on the back of my channel so
I can get your contact details what's
going to happen next is I'm going to
post a Star Wars Episode 8 episode 9
obi-wan Kenobi video Star Wars has a
plan for obi-wan so I'm going to explain
that
in why you just haven't heard a whole
lot about him recently what you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for the trailer for the next episode of
the flash and you can click here to
learn all about the Batman vs Holly
Quinn in the Gotham City sirens movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you